[음악]
안녕하세요
강남 최고의 도로인
도산대로
엠포리아타워에 오신 것을 환영합니다
엠포리아 타워가 위치한 도산대로는
신사역 사거리와 영동대교 남단을 있는
대로로
신세계나 한성 그리고 현대차 모터스
스튜디오 등 유명 기업들과
고급차
매장들이
밀집되어 있는 곳입니다
특히
뉴욕의 타임스퀘어를 연상케 하는
화려한 전광판들이 설치되어 있어
대한민국에서 가장 화려하고
럭셔리한 도로입니다
엠포리아 타워는
도산대로 한 가운데 위치하고 있습니다
엠포리아타운은 대지가 890제곱미터
연면적이
5200 제곱미터로
지하 2층에
지상 15층 규모의
빌딩입니다 그리고 용적률은 약
450%를 받았고 최근에
리모델링을 맞춰서
깔끔하고
고급스러운 빌딩으로
새롭게
탄생을 했습니다 주차는 자주식 세대
기계식
46대로
총
49대에 주차가 가능합니다 그래서
입주사나
방문객이 주차하기에 많이 확보가 되어
있습니다 건물의 첫인상을 좌우하는
로비에는 대리석 마감과
높은 층고로
엠포리아 타워만에
웅장함과
깔끔한 인상을 심어줄 수 있도록
하였고요 그 승강기는 2대가 설치가
되어 있어
임차인이나
고객분들이 사용하기에 전혀 불편함이
없습니다 1층에
들어오면 1층과 2층이 연결되는 내부
계단이 있습니다 그래서 1 2층을
같이 사용하는 임차인들에게 좋은
공간입니다 또한 넓은 발코니가
설치되어 있어 더 넓은 공간을
활용하실 수 있습니다 공용 부분은
회색 타일로 마감이 되어 있어서
모던한 느낌을 주고
화장실은 남녀 구분이 되어 있습니다
지금 있는 3층은 임대 면적이 약
100평으로
높은 층고 때문에 더 넓은 느낌을
주며
외부 발코니가 설치가 되어 있어 더
공간 활용도가 높습니다 그리고 마지막
하이라이트인
맨 꼭대기층에 올라가면
엠포리아 타워만에 놀라운 표가
펼쳐집니다
[음악]
아낌없이
북쪽으로는
신사동 압구정동 한강까지 뷰가 보이며
남쪽으로는
논현동과 역삼동
뷰가 펼쳐집니다 그리고 야간에는
도산대로의 화려한 전광판과 남쪽의
테헤란로 고층빌딩의
화려한 오피스 빌딩의 뷰를 감상할 수
있습니다이
영상을 즐겁게 보셨다면
구독과 좋아요를 눌러주시고
도산대로의 위치한 엠포리아타워 소개를
마치도록 하겠습니다
[음악]